this video was made possible by news
voice a democratized news app created to
fight back against the filter bubbles
caused by corporate media download for
free from news voice calm slash Pakman
or click the link under this video hey I
think you're going to like this next
story Donald Trump had a rally recently
where he called an Obama bill one of his
greatest ideas even though it's a bill
that was passed in 2014 and has
absolutely nothing whatsoever to do with
President Donald Trump and he's actually
said it many times now at rallies Donald
Trump has said at a bunch of different
rallies that he came up with this great
idea for veterans choice and that it
took 44 years to get the legislation
passed and that he alone was able to do
it
every aspect of Trump story about this
is a lie and some of those aspects even
directly conflict with each other so
check this out from a few days ago in
Elko Nevada
you know 44 years they've been trying to
pass these things choice so that a
veteran is sick he gets out of line he's
got to wait forever he's got to wait
forever days weeks months and we just
passed after 44 years we just got a past
I signed it two months ago yeah so the
argument here is that we've been waiting
for 44 years for this thing and that
Trump was able to do it and then here's
from a couple minutes later in the same
speech Trump just completely and totally
off the rails I don't know that there's
anything true about what he says here
we're pretty good at getting things
approved you know in the VA choice I
thought it was like a genius thing I
thought of because I heard they were
waiting so long months sometimes to see
a doctor and waiting on like can you
imagine even if you have something minor
that a pill a prescription something
easy could do and by the way drug prices
are gonna be coming down you see it
[Music]
but I thought it was so brilliant I came
back to my group I said I got the
greatest idea cuz I haven't been doing
this that long so you know I wasn't like
high on my list but it became high I did
know the veterans were never treated
fairly but I said I have the greatest
idea we're gonna do this if a veteran
has to wait we're gonna send them to a
private doctor we'll pay that bill what
a genius I said I said how good is that
they said sir we've been trying to get
it passed for 44 years so I was good at
getting things passed that's what I did
sounded like there was some kind of a
monkey in the audience there that woman
never has some kind of very strange
screech but this is the reaction that
people have to this stuff everything he
said is a total lie he has repeated this
many times at rallies he said it in
Pennsylvania earlier this month he said
it in Kentucky earlier this month the
truth is Obama signed this into law on
August 7th 2014 the veterans Choice
Program created by the bipartisan
veterans access choice and
Accountability Act established that this
is something available to veterans
it passed the Senate 90 one two three it
passed the house for twenty two five and
it lets veterans as Trump says who are
unable to schedule an appointment within
30 days of their preferred date can get
access to non VA health care entities
and providers Trump didn't do anything
related to this except now you might say
well David hold on a second Trump
doesn't usually completely make things
up whole cloth and I would say well yes
he does but there is the tiniest little
connection to Trump what Trump did is he
signed something which allows funding to
keep flowing to this program so the
program is not getting defunded because
Donald Trump is allowing it to continue
this is part of the erasure erasure
erasure I've always found it hard to say
that word this is part of erasing Barack
Obama's legacy which Trump wants to do
most of what Obama did Trump tries to
undo by executive order
by defunding we've talked about that in
the context of Obamacare he's also now
taking Obama's accomplishments that he
likes and claiming he did it himself but
as you heard there from the unhinged
screeching in the crowd
his followers loved it the crowd cheers
and this is why I say Pat that it almost
doesn't matter what he does it's what
can he claim to have done to his
followers and that applies to trade and
tariffs that applies to repealing
Obamacare it doesn't matter what he does
it's what can he sell as an
accomplishment to his followers and
unfortunately he's selling a lot of
stuff to them yeah everything that Obama
did a bad job at Trump is now undoing
and he has new policies putting he's
putting forward everything that Obama
did a did well at Trump's now taking
credit for that too and we can't be
surprised really that Trump is now
taking credit for the veterans Choice
Program because he's been taking credit
for Obama's economy for two years now we
look at unemployment GDP all these other
economic indicators there's no real
change there's no point where Trump
takes office and these these indicators
all of a sudden do much much better it's
really just the continuation of Obama's
economy so he'll continue to do this for
the remainder of his presidency yeah
that actually came up at remember my
interview with Jesse Lee Peterson in LA
I guess at this point it's been a week
or two ago where Jesse Lee Peterson
wanted to focus merely on job creation
numbers and unemployment numbers which
by the way when it was Obama's
presidency they claimed were fake
numbers and when I said to him it's all
great when the economy does well what
once we decide what the indicators are
but what does Trump actually done in
order to achieve those results they
don't have so Jesse Lee Peterson had no
answers other right-wingers seem to be
able to come up with sort of vague
claims like he's reduced regulations
which we know is actually not true or
sort of these amorphous claims but it is
that is that like an unfair question Pat
should the numbers speak for themselves
or is it fair to say okay you've
identified a metric now tell me what you
did in order to achieve that the totally
fair question and of course Jesse
couldn't answer it I don't
he has the intellectual curiosity to try
to answer it and that speaks to most of
Trump supporters you're gonna get some
heat for that one but I I would say it
speaks to many Trump supporters follow
me on instagram david pakman follow the
show at david pakman show part two of my
interview with congressman row khanna is
coming up next
people really liking him in the fact
that he doesn't accept pac money that's
next